[Music]
David is with us in Jacksonville Florida
hi David how are you good thanks for
taking my call
sure I've got two quick questions okay
we are on baby step number two we're
about forty thousand in debt between a
car and some credit card debt and I'm in
sales now I get a car allowance $500 a
month and should we include the car and
baby step two or because I get a car
allowances should we handle it
differently you know you know your car
allowance is part of your income and
your car is in your baby step two
because here's the thing if you get
fired you don't get a car allowance
anymore but you still have a car right
you still have a car payment okay no
they don't they don't like say oh you
don't have a car allowance anymore so
now you don't know anything on your car
that's not how it works okay no also
though my expenses I have to put out all
my expenses and then I'm reimbursed you
know and so it's making you know fudging
a little hard because I don't I can't
really budget it between gas and you
know how much are your expenses are line
stuff
how much is your expense account a month
I don't know what do you usually spend
that is reimbursable in a month it's
usually about 1,500 okay so set up a
separate checking account and let's put
1,500 bucks on it with a debit card on
that account never leave it completely
separate never yeah never use that
account for anything that is not
reimbursable okay and you'll never have
to touch again because every time you
take 500 out or 800 out 800 500 is going
to come back in because they pay their
bill back to you but it's just it's just
a business to delay right right right
and we were trying to do it out of our
you know out of our regular checking
account drive me nuts but it was messing
up yeah right drive you nuts plus you
forget what's impossible when you're
traveling you do buy some things
that are not reimbursable cackling I
mean yeah Shampoo is not reimbursable
you know I mean you know so I don't have
that issue but but you know whatever
right I mean whatever it is you're
buying this a personal item is not
reimbursable you know what that is and
the problem is is that it's all
commingled so if you're on the road and
you buy something that's not
reimbursable you would use your personal
account for that right but you'd use
your your expense account that we set up
on the side just now only for
reimbursable and that way you'll never
have to fund it again you fund it one
time and they give you the money back
each time they give you the money back
each time they give you the money back
each time so it'll always be there as
long as you don't go over 1,500 you'll
never be in the hole right right right
yeah so maybe put two thousand in there
if you want just to make sure but it
makes your life a lot easier to just
keep it very very segmented like that
very compartmentalized departmentalized
so you break it out so good question
hey thank you for joining us